[Music]
[Music]
we had an enormous amount of fun on the
first film
[Music]
good good excellent
there was an energy on set that it was
the first time you'd ever seen anything
like this
[Music]
i was excited about everything that it
could be
when i saw the dinosaur in the trailer
and i saw the ripples on the water i was
like oh my gosh it really defined my
generation this film
i cried the first time i saw dinosaurs
suddenly that which had never seemed
real before
now was totally real and i realized at
that moment that cinema forever had
changed
jurassic world dominion is the
culmination of the franchise it
concludes a story that steven spielberg
started telling in 1993
when we're making jurassic world i knew
it was going to be really special
i could never have imagined we'd be
you're working alongside samuel and jeff
goldblum and laura dern it's pretty
fantastic
it is so much fun it is everything we
could have ever hoped for and more i
thought it was a fantastic idea to bring
these two worlds together
it's been a great privilege to be a
custodian of something like this our
legacy characters our jurassic world
characters are back
our storylines intersect it's the
convergence of the two franchises
we need to fix a terrible mistake and
most importantly go on a true
honest-to-god scary as hell adventure
this is what everything has been leading
to i could use your expertise you coming
or what
[Music]
why
do they always have to go bigger
don't move
[Music]
you